hi I'm Mike Huckabee I'm here on the  campus of Hillsdale College as Americans  can we fully appreciate the precious  Liberty we have if we don't understand a  document that makes that Liberty  possible well let me tell you about  Hillsdale colleges online course  introduction to the Constitution and  it's offered free to anyone with a  desire to learn in this course you'll  join dr. Larry Arn  president of Hillsdale College as he  teaches you the principles of Liberty on  which our great nation was built here  into the lively discussions that take  place around the table and explore the  implications and the beauty of our  Constitution the United States  Constitution is unique in all of human  history I encourage you to come and  discover how truly blessed we are go to  Hillsdale edu slash Constitution that's  Hillsdale dot edu slash Constitution and  sign up for this free course today